Behind the scenes deployments
manage replica sets.
Each deployment is mapped
to one active replica set.
Use kubectl get replicasets command
to view the current set of replicas.
Replicasets are scaled to
the deployment for each service and
can be scaled independently.
As mentioned before, the real strength
of kubernetes come when you work in
a declarative way, instead of using
imperative scale and expose commands.
Let me show you how to scale
the front end deployment using
an existing deployment
configuration file.
First, let's see how many of
our hello pods are running.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Currently we only have one.
We'll change that by
updating the replicas field
of our deployment manifest.
Then we'll apply the change.
Now we look at our replicasets, we can
see information about what's happening.
That desired number of
replicas was updated.
I can use to get pods command
to watch the pods come online.
We'll see the correct
number of pods here.
Now we can check that the deployment
of that it is the correct
number of replicas.
Yep, looks like we now have three
replicas that the deployment
is managing.
And we can still hit our
end point like before.
At this point we now have multiple
copies of our Hello service
running in kubernetes and
we have a single front in service that's
proxying traffic to all three pods.
This allows us to share the load and
scale our containers and kubernetes.